[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
me
what did you think of tonight you kind
of stole the show it was so down the
house now Simon came up to you on this
carpet he was visiting with you and you
had tears in your eyes what was he
saying to you how amazing he is why are
you emotional what is it about this
because he's been working his butt off
to get here and he's worked so hard and
he's just he made it all the way I mean
this is almost like making it to the top
I mean this is this is what he's always
wanted to do he's wanted to perform in
front of thousands of people and this is
in front of millions of people like he's
he's superseded is that the word yeah
you just superseded you know what he's
you know what he thought like he because
we were going for a thousand and it's a
million oh my gosh thank you how do you
pick the song for next week assuming you
get through which you will oh my gosh
that takes a while it is hard to decide
which is the next song it's many times
is it freaked you out a little bit to
know that we're in the Dolby theatre
right now this is where the Oscars are
held this is like on Hollywood Boulevard
in the heart of Hollywood what does that
mean I don't know what that something
you want to do I know one day because
you're in the same kind of place we're
like the Oscars are in stuff oh my gosh
[Laughter]
oh my goodness what's your next goal
that you blended to perform for for them
the Grammy